اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
ساعه اخباريه مفصله من العربيه نستعرض
ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات فيها بدايتها
بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
المرصد يقول ان الغارات الاسرائيليه
استهدفت مواقع سوريا بينها لوائين في
الجولان ودرعا
مستوطنون اسرائيليون يقتحمون باحات الاقصى
وقوات الامن الاسرائيليه تحول المسجد
لتكنه عسكريه
وسط تحذيراتنا امريكيه تايوان ترصد تسع
بوارج وقرابه 60 مقاتله صينيه حول الجزيره
مسؤولون امريكيون يرجحون ان روسيا او
مجموعات مواليه لها وراء تسريب وثائق
البنتاغون
حياكم الله نبدا من التوتر المتزايد على
الحدود الشماليه الاسرائيليه اذ اعلنت تل
ابيب انها قصفت مجمعا لجيش النظام السوري
وانظمه رادار عسكريه ومواقع ايضا مدفعيه
تستخدمها قوته من دون تحديد مكان المواقع
المستهدفه قبل ذلك قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه قصف بواسطه طائره مسيره منصات لاطلاق
صواريخ من سوريا وذلك ردا على ثلاث عمليات
لاطلاق صواريخ من سوريا باتجاه الجولان
المحتل واوضح الجيش الاسرائيلي ان منظومه
القبه الحديديه تمكنت من اعتراض صاروخ
فيما سقط صاروخان في منطقه مفتوحه من جنوب
الجولان كما قصف الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالمدفعيه ايضا موقعا في درعا السوريه بعد
اطلاق الصواريخ فيما تبنى فصيل يدعى لواء
القدس في سوريا اطلاق الصواريخ من جانبيه
ايضا مشاهدينا قالت وزاره دفاع النظام ان
الدفاعات الجويه تصدت لهجوم اسرائيلي
بالصواريخ جنوب البلاد واعترضت بعضا منها
مضيفه ان الهجمات ادت الى وقوعي بعض
الخسائر الماديه دون سقوط قتل او مصابي
هذا وكانت وسائل اعلام سوريا افادت بسماع
دوي انفجارات في محيط العاصمه دمشق مشيره
الى انه يجري التحقق من طبيعه هذه
الانفجارات
من جهه ياكد الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان له
انه يحمل الدوله السوريه المسؤوليه عن
جميع الانشطه التي تحدث داخل اراضيها
معتبرا انه لن يسمح باي محاولات لانتهاك
السياده الاسرائيليه على حد قوله ومن
جانبه كشف مدير مرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
رامي عبد الرحمن للعربيه ان الغارات
الاسرائيليه استهدفت اللواء 90 قربا
الجولان كما استهدفت اللواء 52 في ريفي
درعاب الشرقي
اللواء 90 في منطقه القنيطره قرب الجولان
السوري المحتل وايضا استهدفت اللواء 52 في
ريف درعا الشرقي واستهدفت كتيبه للرادارات
في ريف السويداء الغربي بالاضافه للقصف
المدفعي الذي اوقفت من الدبابات الذي
استهدف مناطق عند يعني في عند الحدود مع
الجولان المحتال سواء الغربي او ريف
القنيطره المتداخل مع ريف درعا الغرب
من القدس تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه لانك
الغاسي لان مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره
ابدا بالسؤال عن البيان الاسرائيلي
التعليق الاسرائيلي على هذه الغارات التي
استهدفت عدد من المواقع في الاراضي
السوريه ماذا لديك من معلومات لنا
اهلا بك نايف فعليا حسب بيان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال بان قوات او طائرات حربيه
عسكريه تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي قامت
بتنفيذ عده غارات على مواقع مختلفه في
سوريا منها موقع عسكري تابع للنظام السوري
وايضا مواقع اخرى من حيث تم اطلاق
الصواريخ من سوريا باتجاه الجولان المحتل
وتم وتقول ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي انه يحمل
الدوله السوريه هذه المسؤوليه لان هذه
الصواريخ تم اطلاقها من الاراضي السوريه
وبذلك الدوله السوريه هي من تتحمل هذه
المسؤوليه اضافه لذلك هناك ايضا يعني تقوم
القوات الاسرائيليه رد فعل على هذه
الصواريخ التي تمت اطلاقها من جنوب سوريا
كان هناك اكثر من سته قذائف صاروخيه تم
اطلاقها من جنوب سوريا الى مواقع
في الجولان السوري المحتل القبه الحديديه
اعترضت صاروخ واحد وبعض الصواريخ ايضا قد
يعني وقعت في مناطق مفتوحه ولا يوجد اي
اصابات او اللاماديه ولا بشريه التي قامت
الشرطه الاسرائيليه بالتصريح عنها وبذلك
ايضا هناك يعني مراقبون يقولون بان قوه
الردع الاسرائيلي على ما يبدو انها تنخفض
بشكل كبير وهذا ايضا ما يزيد يعني قلق
الاسرائيليين قوه الردع يعني كما ذكرت لنا
او يعني نقلا عن بعض المراقبين
يعني لماذا تقلصت هذه القوه هل تحدثت
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه او وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي ايضا كذلك عن هذه القوه قوه
الردع هل تحدث ايضا كذلك عن اي تصعيد
محتمل في الرد الاسرائيلي لا يتوقف فقط
على هذه
على ما حدث من من قصف الاراضي السوريه
ليله البارحه
في طبيعه الحال عندما يتم هناك اطلاق
صواريخ على اسرائيل تقوم بالرد اما
المباشر ولو اما ان تقوم فعليا باطلاق
صواريخ او قذائف فعليا وهي قويه تكون يكون
الرد قوي ولكن هذه المره ما نشرها ما
نشهده فعليا هو رد بسيط ومحدود على ما
يبدو ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه والحكومه
اليمنيه الحاليه بسبب التوترات الداخليه
لا تريد تصعيد اكبر ولا تريد ان تدخل في
يعني تهديدات امنيه خارجيه اكبر من ذلك
لذلك على ما يبدو ان الرد الاسرائيلي
حاليا يكون مدروس بدقه كبيره وهم يعني
يؤكدون بانهم لا يريدون تصعيد اكبر وانما
فقط الرد على هذه الصواريخ وبذلك
المراقبون يقولون بان اسرائيل حاليا قوه
الردع لديها منخفضه بشكل كبير وذلك بسبب
الرد القليل والغير معتاد من قبل اسرائيل
بهذه الطريقه اشكرك يا جزيل الشكر من
القدس انضمت الينا مراسله العربيه لانك
الغاسي
نذكر بهذا الخبر العاجل اسفل الشاشه يتحدث
عن ان الطالبان اعتقلت ثلاثه من عناصر
داعش في ولايه
تحدثت ايضا قبل ذلك عن اشتباكات بين
طالبان وداعش في ولايه
نيمروز اقصى جنوب البلاد الاعلام الافغاني
ايضا يتحدث عن اعتقال طالبان
لثلاثه
اشخاص من من داعش من عناصر داعش طبعا في
ولايه نيمروز اقصى جنوب البلاد كما يظهر
في شريط العاجل اسفل الشاشه بالعوده الى
هذه النشره فدت مصادر العربيه في القدس
باقتحام قرابه 280 مستوطنا المسجد الاقصى
حتى السابعه صباحا جاءت هذه الاقتحامات
على عده مجموعات تحت حراسه مشدده من
الشرطه وادى المستوطنون طقوسا دينيه وكشفت
وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه عن قيام الجيش
الاسرائيلي بتحويل باحات المسجد الاقصى
الى تكنه عسكريه حيث نصبت القوات
الاسرائيليه الحواجز داخل اسوار البلده
القديمه وافرغت كذلك الشوارع من الشبان
تمهيدا الاقتحام المستوطنين
في الاثناء تواصل الحكومه المصريه
مشاهدينا جهودها لتخفيف حده التوتر وعدم
التصعيد بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
مصادر العربيه افادت ايضا بان القاهره دعت
اسرائيل صباح السبت الى عدم الاقدام على
استهداف قيادات الفصائل منعا لاشتعال
الوضع كما حضرت المسؤولين الامنيين
الوسطاء ايضا كذلك من ان سياسه الاغتيالات
الاسرائيليه
ستنهي الهدنه تماما كما ذكرت مصادر
العربيه ان القاهره طالبت ايضا برفع اي
قيود على المصلين والمعتكفين في المسجد
الاقصى منعا لاتساع الازمه اذا نظم عشرات
الالاف من الاسرائيليين امس السبت في تل
ابيب احتجاجات مناهضه لخطط رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو لتغيير النظام القضائي
مطالبين بالغائه وليس فقط بتاجيله
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل ايضا
مسؤول ايراني يؤكد قدره بلاده على تخصيب
اليورانيوم باي نسبه وفي اي وقت
حياكم الله من جديد قال رئيس منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه محمد اسلامي ان طهران
لديها القدره على تخصيب اليورانيوم متى
شاءت وباي نسبه كانت واضاف اسلامي في
مقابله مع التلفزيون الايراني ان هدف
الولايات المتحده كان ايقاف التكنولوجيا
النوويه الايرانيه لكنها فشلت في ذلك ولم
تحقق اي نتائج بحسب تعبيره
اكد الجيش الصيني الاستمرار في مناورات
تطويق جزيره تايوان والمياه المحيطه بها
وقال الجيش الصيني في بيان انه نفذ محاكاه
لتوجيه ضربات دقيقه على اهداف الرئيسيه
داخل تايوان ومحيطها عبر عشرات المقاتلات
الجويه والقوات البريه واشار الجيش ايضا
الى زياده زخم المناورات من جهه اعلن
الجيش التايواني راست 9 سفن حربيه
وثمانون مقاتله جويه صينيه حول الجذع
الجزيره وقالت ايضا في صدد هذا الموضوع
مصادر امريكيه في تايوان ان الولايات
المتحده تراقب المناورات الصينيه حول
تايوان عن كتب وانها تشعر بالارتياح
والثقه لامتلاكها ما يكفي من موارد وقدرات
على الصعيد الاقليمي لضمان السلام
والاستقرار حسب قولهم وبدات الصين التي
تقول ان تايوان جزء من اراضيها تدريبات
عسكريه امس على
مدى ثلاثه ايام حول الجزيره بعد يوم من
عوده رئيسه تايوان
من زياره للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره بدايه ما الذي
يفسر هذا الطوق العسكري الكبير ان صحه
التعبير حول تايوان
اهلا ومرحبا بكم هذا هذه المناورات هي
اشاره تحضيريه للانفصاليين
وكذلك
للرفضهم لتوحيد باستخدام القوه وهذا هو
تحضير ايضا
القوه الخارجيه الدعم لها مثل الولايات
المتحده واليابان ولذلك ايضا هو لاظهار
عزيمه
الصين الثابت للدفاع عن سيادتها ووحده
ارادها بان لدى جيش التحرير الشعبي الصيني
القدره الكافيه لتنفيذ محيمه التوحيد كامل
للبلاد فيمكن ان نرى الطوق اصبح اضيق وفي
النهايه سيكون يعني
الضمن جزيره تايوان العوده العوده حقيقيه
سيتم في ذلك اليوم الطوق اضيق هذه الجمله
يتم استخدامها من الصينيين بعد زياره رئيس
التايوان الى الولايات المتحده هل هذه
الخطوه مرتبطه برد فعل الصين على هذه
الزياره املا الامر هو عباره عن تراكمات
من ما تعتقد بكين بانه
يعني مجموعه من الاخطاء
التايوان التي ادت الى هذه الحاله
العسكريه والى هذا الزخم الكبير حول جزيره
تايوان
طبعا هذا يعني اولا هو الردا للقبور
للولايات المتحده واللقائه مع مسؤولين
الامريكيين هناك
وهذا يخالف مبدا واحد ثم هو ايضا
لسلسله من التحركات الانفصاليين في تايوان
الى الاستقلال يعتمادا على الولايات
المتحده
وبعدهم الى السلطه في عام
[موسيقى]
1916 فهم رفضوا
المبدا السنه الواحد وكذلك رفض الجميع
التبادلات مع ابارئيسي وسعي الى الاستقلال
وكل هذا يعني هو
الردود القويه من جيش التحرير الشعب
الصيني هو بسبب
السارهم الى الاستقلال الجيش يقول بانه
قام بمناورات ومحاكاه لضرب مواقع واهداف
رئيسيه في تايوان هل الصين سيد نادر
متاهبه هل هي جاده فعلا لتنفيذ هكذا نوع
هكذا ضربات على اهداف رئيسيه في تايوان
اما ان هذا فقط استعراض
القوه او تصريحات من اجل يعني ربما اخافه
تايوان من اي خطوات او علاقات دبلوماسيه
قد تتعمق اكثر مع الولايات المتحده
اعتقد هذا هو يعني موقف جاد يعني الجيش
التحرير الشعبي الصيني او كذلك لدي الاجار
في القوات الصواريخ
الجادون لتنفيذ اي هذه المهمه في اي لحظه
من اللحظات ولكن
يعني تحب السلام وما زال يعني تتحمل يعني
تتحلى باقصى درجه من الصبر
وتوحيد يعني السلمي مازال الخيار الاول
ولكن هذا يتوقف على سلوك
يعني رئيس الانفصاليين في تايلاند اذا
استمرت في استفتازات
التوحيد باستخدام القوه سيتم يعني
[موسيقى]
وهذا ايضا كل الاسباب ترجعوا الى سعرهم
الى الاستقرار الذي يؤدي الى الصراع الم
فتوحه في اعلى جانب الماضيه شكرا جزيلا لك
من بكينا انضم الينا الصحفي نادي
رغم التصريحات رغم المواقف الاوروبيه ايضا
من الصين وخطرها على النظام العالمي
تتوالى زياراته كبار القاده
الاوروبيين الى بكين اخر وكانت للرئيس
الفرنسي ورئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبي فمن هم
من منهم بحاجه الى الاخر نتابع
بين هذه الجلسه وهذه الحفله رسائل وسياسات
ومواقف كثيره ربما لم تقل صراحه لكنها
حضرت بقوه مواقف صدرت الى الواجهه وابقت
على رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه فان دايلاين
خلف الكوارث
العلاقه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي وبكين كانت
تعرضت للتارجح منذ بدء الحرب الاوكرانيه
داعما لبوتين في حربه على كيف ومنافسا
يريد تغيير النظام العالمي اضافه لكونها
منافسا على مركز التاثير والقياده عالميا
عادهاجها نظاما قمعيا في الداخل الصيني
اتهامات تنفيها بكين بالمقابل لا يريد
الاتحاد الاوروبي التخلي عن الصين في وقت
باتت العلاقات مع الجاره موسكو محكومه
بشبه قطيعه الا من انبوب غاز
الصين شريك اقتصادي كبير للاتحاد الاوروبي
صدرت خلال العام الماضي سته ملايين
واربعمائه الف حاويه الى الاسواق
الاوروبيه الى جانب كونها البديل الابرز
للطاقه الروسيه في خطه الاوروبيين
للانتقال الى الطاقه النظيفه واكبر
المؤثرين في قضيه تغير المناخ وبين شد
وجذب واتهام ونفي تقول الانباء نصين كانت
واجهه لكبار قاده اوروبا خلال العام
الاخير اسبان والمان واخيرا الفرنسيون
ومعهم اوزولا فونديلاين امر قد يشهي بمن
هو اكثر حاجه للاخر
قالت القياده الجنوبيه للجيش الاوكراني ان
الاسطول البحري الروسي في البحر الاسود
يحتفظ بحاملتي صواريخ تحمل قذائف من طراز
كاليفر بالاضافه الى غواصتين من الصعب
اعتراض صواريخهما عبر وسائل الدفاع الجوي
واشارت الى ان اعلان التاهب بسبب خطر
اطلاق صواريخ من البحر الاسود يعني انه من
الضروري على السكان التحرك باسرع ما يمكن
بعد اختفائهم لشهور في روسيا عاد اكثر من
ثلاثين طفلا اوكرانيا الى ديارهم بعد
عبورهم الحدود الاوكرانيه الروسيه فيما
تتهم السلطات الروسيه باحتجاز الاف
الاطفال قصرا في معسكرات اعتقاد قافله
منتظر شهور بالف عام في تقويم الامهات هنا
وصل الصغار اخيرا بعدما اختفوا في ظروف
الحرب واحتجزتهم روسيا قصرا في معسكرات
اعتقال
عوده الى اوكرانيا لحوالي 30 طفلا من
روسيا الى اوكرانيا احتجزوا خلال الحرب في
روسيا بعيدا عن اهاليهم دون القدره على
التواصل معهم وفق روايه الاطفال
لقد عمرنا مثل الحيوانات احتجزنا في مبنى
منفصل
يقولون لنا كل يوم ان والدينا رفضون واننا
غير مرغوبين
منظمه انقاذ اوكرانيا اشرفت على عمليه لم
شمل الاطفال وعودتهم الى ديارهم مهمه
معقده استمرت طويلا
الان توشيك مهمه انقاذ الخامس على
الانتهاء سيصل 31 طفلا خلال 43 ساعات
لكياف كان الامر خاصا ومعقدا فيما يتعلق
الاطفال الذين تمكنا من اعادتهم
قدرت كييف عدد الاطفال المختطفين في روسيا
ب
19500 طفل اوكراني منذ فبراير الماضي فيما
تواجه موسكو اذانات دوليه ضدها رغم نفيها
لجميع الاذنات غذاء السالم العربيه
المتاعب القانونيه تلاحق الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب المحاكمه الاشهر التي
تجري في نيويورك ليست هي الوحيده القضاء
في ولايه جورجيا يسعى ايضا لمتابعه المرشح
الجمهوري
بخصوص محاوله تشويش على الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في عام 2020 نتابع
[موسيقى]
يطلب اكثر من 11 الف صوت اضافي في ولايه
جورجيا هذا مقطع من مكالمه هاتفيه مدتها
ساعه دارت في الثاني من يناير 2021 بين
دونالد ترامب
السياسي الجمهوري الذي يشغل منصبا رفيعا
في ولايه جورجيا
هذا التسجيل هو في قلب ملف قضائي اخر قد
يجلب الرئيس السابق امام محكمه في ولايه
جورجيا الامريكيه بتهمه محاوله تغيير
نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي فاز بها
جو بايدن
المدعيه العامه للمقاطعه في ولايه جورجيا
فاني ويليس تعمل منذ اكثر من عامين على
التحقيق حول هذا التسجيل وما اذا كان يشكل
جريمه قد تنهي امال في الترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه في عام 2004
لكن الدراما القانونيه السياسيه لن تتوقف
هنا فالجمهوريون في هذه الولايه الصغيره
بدروا باتخاذ اجراءات ضد المدعيه العامه
ونادوا بالغاء التحقيق واقالتها لانها
دعمت مرشحا ديموقراطيا بتنظيمها لحمله
تبرعات تهمت المدعيه العامه بان التحقيق
القضائي الذي تقوده بخصوص ترامب ما هو الا
حمله سياسيه مغرضه هدفها عرقله مساعيه
الانتخابيه
ثاني ويليس لم تعلن اتخاذ اي اجراءات
قانونيه تجاه ترامب حتى الان ولكن مصادر
صحفيه امريكيه تقول ان السلطات مقاطعه
فولتون تقوم بتعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه حول
مقر الادعاء العام والمحكمه وهذا قد يكون
مؤشرا على استدعاء قريب للترامب انس لماسي
العربيه
الان في شريط الاخبار العاجله تنقل بان 10
سفن صينيه ومثل تايوانيه على خط المواجهه
في مضيقي تايوان نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد
الفاصل قائد قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه بعد
نجاته من محاوله اغتيال يتهم تركيا ويقول
انه ليس الاول ولن يكون الاخير
المرصد يقول ان الغارات الاسرائيليه
استهدفت مواقع السوريه بينها لوائين في
الجولان ودرعا
مستوطرون اسرائيل هناك اقتحمون باحات
الاقصى وقوات الامن الاسرائيليه تحول
المسجد لثكنه عسكريه
وسط تحذيرات امريكيه تايوان ترصد تسع
بواري جوابه 60 مقاتله صينيه حول الجزيره
مسؤولون امريكيون يرجحون ان روسيا او
مجموعات مواليه لها وراء تسريب وثائق
البنتاجون
حياكم الله من جديد قال القائد العام
لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي ان
الهجوم بالمسيره التركيه وقع اثناء عوده
موكبه الذي يضم عددا من المسؤولين
الامريكيين واعضاء من مكافحه الارهاب واكد
عبدي ان هدف تركيا من هذا الهجوم هو افشال
الجهود المشتركه مع الحلفاء والعراق
واقليمي كردستان في محاربه الارهاب وداعش
مشيرا الى ان هذه ليست المره الاولى التي
يتم استهدافه ولن تكون الاخيره على حد
وصفه
من القامشلي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
جماعه مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره يعني
نريد ان نجمل ابرز ما قاله مظلوم عبدي في
هذه التصريحات بعد هذا الهجوم بهذه
المسيره التركيه
نعم يعني هذا هو الفيديو هو الذي يظهر فيه
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مصدومه والذي يؤكد
بانه كان متواجدا في السليمانيه بعد كمها
الميناء التكتم والمعلومات المتضاربه في
هذه في هذا الفيديو اكد مصدوم عبدي بانه
كان مع مجموعه من الامريكيين وموات مكافحه
الارهاب وانه كان متواجد في مطار
السليمانيه وان مسيره تركيا يعني استهدفت
موكب موكب مظلوم عبد الذي عاد بسلامه وامل
الى شمال شرق سوريا حيث يمارس اعماله
مصدوم عبدي اكد بان هدف تركيا هو استثمار
هذه العمليه الانتخابيا واستخدامها كورق
الضغط في تركيا للتاثير على الحمله
الانتخابيه وايضا تعكيل صف المتناميه بين
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والاتحاد الوطني
لكره الطرف الابرز في اللعبات السياسيه في
اقليم كردستان العراق وايضا التاثير على
منحه الحرب ضد 11 هكذا لقب موضوع ابرز
اهداف تركيا في استهدافه في السليمانيه
مساء ليله الجمعه الاستهداف هل كان للمطار
مطار السليمانيه ام كان لموكب مظلوم عبده
الذي كان متجها بالفعل الى المطار من
كانوا يرافقه ايضا هناك حديث ربما ايضا
حتى هو اكده بان هناك امريكي كان يرافقه
في هذا
الموكب لكن لا نعلم هل كان متجها الى
المطار هل كان هذا الموكب موجود اصلا في
المطار جمعه
مصدوم يتحرك بمرافقه عناصر امريكيين
يعملون في سياق التحالف الدولي لمكافحه
داعش مصدوم كان متواجدا في مطار
السليمانيه في طريقه الى شمال شرق سوريا
وتحديدا الى مدينه الحسكه عندما وجهت له
طائره مسيره تركيه صاروخين على الاقل وقعت
على محيط المطار فيما يبدو انها كانت يعني
صواريخ تحذيريه لربما اذا لم يكن في موكب
مصدوم عبدي يعني امريكيين لربما كانت هذه
الصواريخ ستزادفه بشكل مباشر ربما تركي
ارادت تفادي اي يعني صدام مباشر مع
واشطر حتى لو كان ذلك كان خارج الاراضي
الامريكيه او خارج اراضي شمال شرق سوريا
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من القامشلي مراسل
العربيه جمعه كاش
[موسيقى]
في العراق نهر دجله اليوم يختلف كثيرا عن
الامس فهو يعاني من ارتفاع في نسب التلوث
تجعله غير صالح للاستخدام البشري او
الزراعي عدد كبير من العراقيين عبروا عن
استيائهم من مدى تلوث مياه نهر دجلاب
وكذلك مدى تاثيره السلبي على الصيد
والبيئه نتابع
ريحه وساخه يعني هي العالم هي سبب التلوث
كليته زين يعني يجي هنا يقعد يذبلك هاي
ابطال يذبلك مدري شنو وقزاز
وعواي هذا كله تلوث
وساخه ننذب بالشبل ساعه كامله ننظف فيه
ثلاثه مسؤولين امريكيين لرويترز ان هناك
احتمالات قويه بان روسيا او مجموعات
مواليه لها وراى تسريب وثائق البنتاغون
الاخيره وذلك مع فتح وزاره العدل تحقيقا
حول مصدر التسريب وتكشف تلك الوثائق
مشاهدينا عن تفاصيل الصراع الاوكراني وخطه
واشنطن لدعم قوات كييف وخاصه مع اقتراب
معركه الربيع
في الاردن تتنوع اشكال الاعمال الخيريه في
رمضان ابرزها تقديم المساعدات للعوائل
المتعففه والمحتاجين ايضا من خلال توفير
وجبات الافطار عبر موائد الرحمن ومبادرات
انسانيه اخرى تستهدف المحتاجين وتؤمن
افطارهم طيله ايام الشهر الفضيل
[موسيقى]
السبيل والمحتاج والاف الاسر العفيفه
يتجمعون هنا في المكان نفسه والوقت ذاته
من كل عام مشهد بات تقليدا اصيلا في رمضان
فيه موائد الرحمن تستقبل الصائمين وتقدم
لهم وجبات الافطار بحب لا يقابل الا
بالكثير من الحب ودعوه من القلب نقوم على
خدمه حوالي 3500 صائم يوميا بقوم على
خدمتهم حوالي 80 متطوع بالاضافه الى الى
تفاعليه جميله
والمتطوعين بصراحه في عنا ضغط كبير يعني
من المتطوعين اللي هو صار التطوع بين
موائد رحمات تقليد يعني من تقاليد رمضان
بالنسبه لهم زي الفانوس سنوات طويله مرت
وتكيه ام علي تعمل على خدمه الصائمين عمل
وجد به المتطوعون اسمى اهدافهم حتى استمر
الكثير منهم بتحضير الطعام وتقديمه في
تكيه ام علي لاكثر من عشر سنوات كل اشي
بتقدمه هون وحتى بتشوف الناس بتكون مبسوطه
وانت لما تقدمي لهم اشي بتكون يعني في
ايجابي منك ومنهم اكيد شعور بالفرح
انه الاقل حظا والناس المحتاجين اكيد شعور
بالعطاء والعطاء ما له حدود اغتنام وشهري
رمضان في عمل الخير له وجه اخر هنا فتحت
عنوان سبيل صويلح يحضر مجموعه من الشباب
وجبات الافطار للعوائل العفيفه كما يقومون
بالبحث عن اي محتاج تعفف عن السؤال نقوم
بتوزيع ما لا يقل عن 100 صدر يوميا ويصل
العدد في بعض الايام الى 130 140 صدر
يوميا بفضل الله تعالى
نستهدف من يعني عملنا بفضل الله تعالى
الاخوه الذين يستحقون عملنا في هذا الشهر
المبارك وما وضع اقتصادي صعب وسوء احوال
الكثير من المواطنين تقدم هذه المبادرات
الرمضانيه جل ما يحتاجه كثيرون في شهر شرع
ابوابه لاعمال الخير سها جميل العربيه
عمان
[موسيقى]
يحظى الجزء السابع من المسلسل الكوميديه
المصري الكبير قوي من بطوله الفنان احمد
مكي بنسبه مشاهده وتفاعل عاليه خاصه مع
مشاركه عدد من الفنانين كضيوفي شرف المزيد
في تقرير الدراما مع سهى الوعل واعداد
ايهم القاسم
[موسيقى]
انت طيبه بنت حلال بس انا طلبت منك ومن
العيشه معاكي انا هتجوز
[موسيقى]
مرحبا يتواجد النجم احمد مكي بجزء سابع من
مسلسل الكبير اوي هذا العام واللي يعتبر
من قبل البعض حلاوه رمضان كما يصف الجمهور
حيث ياتي مكه بعملك وجبه خفيفه على
المشاهدين نحافظا هذا العام على نفس
مجموعه الممثلين من العام الماضي مع
العديد من كبار الضيوف الشرف من الفنانين
الجزء السابع من مسلسل الكبير اوي نقول ان
هو في الحلقات الاولى تضرر من السقف
التوقعات المرتفع
للجمهور كان مستنيه لانه فعلا الجمهور
ارتبط به بشكل كبير في السنه اللي فاتت
لكن رجع التوازن تاني من بدايه حلقات نزول
الكبير ومربوحه الى القاهره وتعرضها للقطف
النجاح الكبير اللي حققه الجزء السادس من
المسلسل في الحقيقه سقف توقعاته الجمهور
وانت لما تقدم عمل قوي جدا وحقق نجاح كبير
جدا الجمهور بيبقى منتظر منك ان لم يكن
نفس النجاح فبيبقى ازيد اعتقد ان السنه دي
في شيء ما
لسه ما وصلش للجمهور نفس البريق ونفس
التالق ونفس النجاح ونفس الحواديت اللي
جوه المسلسل تنقسم العراق ما بين من يرى
وجوب ايقاف العمل عند هذا الحد واعتبار
الجزء السابع هو الاخير منه بينما هناك
فئه اخرى ترى ان مكي لا يستطيع الخروج من
عباءه الكبير ولذلك لا باس من المحافظه
عليها لكن مع بعض المعتره في الافكار ما
ينفعش نطلع اقول المسلسل يوقف ممكن نقول
طور المسلسل يعني مثلا من اشهر المسلسلات
الكوميدي في العالم اتعمل 10 اجزاء هواوي
اتعمل عشر اجزاء في مسلسلات كتير اتعملت
اجزاء كتير لو جيت شفت حلقه في مسلسل
فريندز وجيت شفتها وجيت شفت حلقه تانيه
بعد موسمين احس ان في تغيير في كل حاجه
يعني هحس الاحداث بتتغير والشخصيات بتتغير
والافهات بتتغير فانا مسلسل الكبير انا لو
اتفرجت على حلقه وجيت فرجت كمان موسمين
هحس ان هي نفس الاحداث لسه
جوني قاعد في المزاريطه يتكلم عربي بقى له
من 2011 تقريبا مسلسل او مش بالظبط لسه
هدرس بنفس الافات فهو الافيه حلاوه ان انت
ما سمعوش قبل كده ما رايكم ان نتوقف
[موسيقى]
مع بعض
التعقيم اتفضل
[موسيقى]
يا اختي
سوريه بينها لوائين في الجولان ودرها
مستوطنون اسرائيليون يقتحمون باحات الاقصى
وقوات الامن الاسرائيليه تحول المسجد
لثقنه عسكريه
وسط تحتنا امريكيه تايوان ترصد تسع بوارج
وقرابه 60 مقاتله صينيه حول الجزيره
مسؤولون امريكيون يرجحون ان روسيا او
مجموعه مواليه لها وراء تسريب وثائق
البنتاغون
شكرا لكم لكرمي ولطف المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات